If you're basically doing
expected value of money calculations,
this isn't the game for you.
Yes, your math is correct.  Don't do it
.  So yes, you're calculating
correctly.  Don't start a startup.
Don't do it.    That
's absolutely correct.
You're making a trade-off where
you sacrifice safety for more risk.
This is Dalton with Michael.  Today we're going to
talk about why you should keep
working on your startup.  So, uh,
give us an introduction.  Look,
it's perfectly understood.  I believe that
most startups die by
suicide rather than homicide.  And that
losing hope is what makes
people give up.
Yes.
And I know that a large part of our
audience are founders or employees of
startups.
Yes.
And I like to think, or I'm told, that
sometimes we inspire them to feel
enthusiastic about what they do.
Yes.
So this is one of those videos
where we'll do our best to motivate you
, providing logic and reasons, not just
adding fuel to the fire.  I suppose that,
to begin with, if you give up, there's no
way you'll succeed.  There's a 100%
chance that the day
you decide to give up, your startup won't have
succeeded, right?
Yes.
This is simply logic.
The natural state of startups is
that they are failing.
Yes.
And I think there can be a kind of
dysmorphia where it seems like
everyone else's startup is doing better than
yours.    That
's not the case.
And therefore, it is not.    It
isn't.    It
isn't.
We can tell you.  We talked
about that.    We
know.  We are aware of it.  So,
right there,
yes.
If you feel like it's really not working, A
, you're probably right, and B, it's what
you should expect.    It
's funny, it's like you're a
freshman in high school
competing against the
seniors, and you lose;  That's how the
game is played.  That's the game, right?  They've
had four more years of
growth and training, and you
can do the same.  The founders get it
into their heads that
successful companies succeed quickly.
And they always have a couple of examples of
what I call "pop examples," like things
that appear on Twitter or TechCrunch.  And
one of the things I think is now
very possible with AI is to obtain the
real facts.
Yes.
Make a list of the 10 companies you
like.  Go to your phone and look at the 10
companies you have there.  And just
ask the AI, how long did it
take them to do x?  And you'll find
some, right?  YouTube was sold
for one billion dollars in about 18
months.
fast.
And then you'll have Nvidia, right?    It
took him a while to figure out his
business.  And I think what I try to
console founders with is that there are
many paths to success and most of them
are longer than you think.
Yes.
So if this is the first year and
you're not a Cursor yet, it's like you don't
have enough evidence yet
to know
if it's going to work or not.  And I think one
of the things I see many
founders do is repeat the first year
over and over again.  Like: "Oh, let's
pivot or I'm going to do something new, but I
can never get past the first year."    I
never get to the point where I
actually know something.  Where
I can actually build a good product.  It's
like: "If it doesn't work too quickly
, I move on to the next thing."  And I think the
warnings are: if you literally
ran out of money, okay, that's one
reason.  If you are literally
suffering, for health reasons.
Yes, okay, that was great.  Yes,
great.
Those are very valid reasons.  But
what if you simply say, "
Wow, why aren't we
conquering the world yet?"  And if we feel
embarrassed or that our expectations are
not being met, I
think you can simply change your
way of thinking.
Yes.
And give yourself enough space to get
lucky.
Yes.
And be your own worst critic.  If you have a
voice in your head telling you
negative things about your startup, um, don't
do that.  That is
self-destructive behavior.  And if you think about it,
you're kind of validating the
bad types of authority figures.
Mhm.
by giving up too soon.  Don't
you want to go against the
system? Don't you want to? Don't you want to
prove everyone wrong
? Don't you want to? Right?
It's curious because this
time period is so common that it has a name.
It's called the Valley of Sadness,
right?  So that's just another
indication that you're not alone.  In
other words, if someone mentions it, almost
everyone is going through it, and almost
everyone had to go through it.  Well, and
again, the founders can talk
about this after they've succeeded.  Like:
"Yeah, we're worth hundreds of
millions now, but man, we really
sucked for a while."
Yes.
So you hear it from them, but
other than that, people don't really
talk about it.
No.
Certainly, investors don't
say:
Here are all my
shitty investments.
Here are all the investments I
made that went horribly wrong.
I guess we're willing to talk
about it, but, you know, there's kind of no
incentive to be honest about it
.  Again, this is the natural and
predetermined state of things.
Yes.
It's as if there's 100% evidence throughout
history that
most startups fail, that
most investments in
startups fail.  Just to put ourselves
in the shoes of those who experience
this, I remember going through this
when I was a founder.  You arrive at
work.  You work hard, but you're not
quite sure what to build.
Yes.
And the ideas change every week.  How to
have a new conversation every day
.
Yes.
And you say, "What if we add agents?"  Or
like: "Oh, like,
yeah. Yeah. You
're just like,
yeah.
Pasting random ideas together.
Unfortunately, you might be
reading a lot of tweets or
tech news about how everyone else is doing
better than you.
Yeah.
And that combination of things makes you
want to change course to copy
what works.
Yeah.
And think, 'Well, those guys aren't that
great.'"  "We're better than...
" You know, some kind of
emotional feeling about it.  Yes.
Probably badly.    You're
probably not talking to
your users.
Yes. And unfortunately, many people
in this state want advice from
authority figures to feel
better.  And so, yes, you
know, again, I guess we're
doing that in a way, which is
moving forward, but sometimes, sometimes
I would have office hours with people
and they would say to me, "Dalton, where
should we pivot?"  And I would tell them,
"I don't know, friend."
Yes, exactly.  Exact.  Which is what
I spent the next 10 years of my
life working on.  Well, I think you
just want to learn to
enjoy this process, realize that it
's normal, and understand that you just need to put in the
effort and find the answer
by talking to your users, launching the
product, and not getting into a bad
mental state, right?
Well, I remember that moment very
clearly and I remember always
going back to thinking, "I'm 23 years old and
I'm running a company."  I mean
, how crazy.  Even if the graphs
show that it is a failing company
.  In the context of how enriching
the experience is and how lucky I am
.
Yes.
This is winning.  Being in this game is
winning.  And I think that always...you
know, I could have some job on
the East Coast where I'm a
subordinate of a subordinate of a
subordinate to the person who makes the
decisions, and I could wait 25 years.
I think the most common bitter pill
, let's address it now, is that I've seen
a lot of tweets saying, "Well,
if you had just gotten a job
at Anthropic 4 years ago, you would have
made a lot more money."  So,
let's dismantle that argument.
Number one, how would you have known
that Anthropic was going to be the chosen one and not
, you know, Airtable or someone else?
Yes. Well, that's...
Yes, that's a point.
Number two, could you really have
gotten a job at Airtable?
Would you have passed Anthropic's technical test
?  I don't know, maybe.  Who
can say?  But, you know...
Of course, of course I would have done it in
hindsight.
Yes, maybe you would have, but I don't
know if you really could have gotten
a job there even if
you had wanted to.  Number three, is that
really what it's
all about?  And if what you're trying to do is make the
most money in the
least risky way possible, don't start a
startup.  Thank you.  Don't do it, friend.
This is not what you want.
These were calculations you could have
made from day one.
If you say, "Oh, heavens, I
should have just gone to Anthropic."  It's
like, well, why did you start a
company? Did you think it would be easy and
that the odds were
high?
This is what I kind of hate, that there's
this idea that if you're basically
calculating the expected value of money
, this isn't your game.  Only...
The math is correct.  Don't do it
.  You're doing the calculations
correctly.  Don't start a startup.  That's
absolutely correct.
And it's not like I'm saying that's a
bad thing, you know?  If that's what
motivates you, I'd say find out what
the next big company will be, and you
could get great expected value
.
Yes.
But only if you want to have your hands on the
controls.
You gain autonomy.  You make a
trade where you gain more autonomy
in exchange for more risk.  And that's not the
right exchange for everyone.
Again, I really don't think
startups are for everyone.
I agree.
You just need to look in the mirror and
say: I made a deal
. Yes,
for more autonomy in exchange for more
risk.  And
yes,
by making that deal, I should at least
keep doing this long enough,
yes,
to have a chance,
yes, that
maybe
something interesting will happen.    Right
?
Well, it's interesting because it's like,
what expected value calculation
are you doing?  If you're doing an
expected cash value calculation,
go work at Google, bro.  If
you're calculating the expected value
of autonomy, excitement, and adventure,
talk to those people.
Yes. Well, they would tell me, well, it was very
exciting working on Anthropic.  And
again, I would say, okay, yes.  But
who? Did you know it was going to...?
Could you have foreseen it? If you could have
predicted that what was going to happen at
Anthropic was what happened...
Yes.
You should be an investor.  So, you
know, you're a super genius, man.  I don't
think most people
predicted it.
No.
Right?
And it's funny because anyone who's
been in the startup game long enough
knows these are
silly conversations.  Like, oh, I could
have worked at Anthropic, right?
Like, oh, I could have invested like an
angel in such.  Oh, here's all the
money I could have earned but didn't
.  It's like, come on.  Go cry in your
soup.  That's not the game we play
here.
Yeah. I mean, you're just going to drive yourself crazy.
Exact.  Exact.  In short: if
you enjoy having your hands on the wheel
, if you enjoy feeling like you can
make the decisions, and if your health or
your bank account, etc., are not an
obstacle, you don't have to stop because it's
not working.  It's not
working for anyone.
You're not the only one.
the only one.
You are not alone.
And if it all works out for you in the end, you'll be
very happy to have gone through it.  You'll
appreciate it more.  Get through this phase for as long
as possible.  And I would say the
following.  It's very different when
I talk to a founder who's been around for about
a year and says, "Wow, this is
painful."  And a founder who has been around for
four years.  Uh, I would say that every
startup has an underlying hypothesis.
And it takes some time to
know the results of that
experiment, right? Do our users
want this? Can we
provide it to them?  Et cetera, et cetera
.  I believe the way to fail is to
give up before having
clear information about whether your hypothesis was
correct.  I think if you want to change
course or make a
different decision because you've learned about your
industry, about the product, about the
customers, and you've realized something
important about the hypothesis that
isn't correct.  Brilliant.  That's ok.
But if you stop because you don't yet
know the answer to your hypothesis,
but you're not succeeding as
quickly as you expected.  Yes. Some
tactical suggestions are to enjoy the
process and try to find wins.
Yes.
And try to feel like you're adding
value to your customers, which has always
been a big theme in our videos.
If you see this as an all-or-nothing thing and
compare yourself to others, bad news,
guys.  If they compare themselves to others,
no matter how much success they achieve, they will still be
sad.
Yes. You
know, that's a secondary matter.  That will
haunt you for life.  Uh, just so
you know.  But, you know,
if instead of valuing your progress by
how much you're learning or how much
initiative you have and how much you're
helping customers,
you can actually move forward even when things are
n't going very well.
Even during the valley of sadness
.
Yes. Yes.
And everyone who comes out of the valley of
sadness is learning while they
are there.  Yes. They don't just sit there with their
arms crossed, feeling bad about
themselves.
Yeah, I don't... It's not public when
we're recording this, so I can't
talk about the details of the
company, but there's a
recent investment I made and I know the founder
and yeah, man, everything went wrong for
2 years.  So, it's a very good idea,
but what are the things that could
go wrong?  It launched early, was overtaken
by the competition, didn't grow for 2
years, fundraising was difficult, its
co-founder quit. No, he didn't
consider applying for jobs.
That's all.
Everyone gave up on him.
Yes, yes.
You know, and it's like it's
totally working, and all I can say I
learned from that story is that the
guy is a tough guy, man.  My respects.
Yes.
Absolutely.  There's really no
lesson there about why
advice that would have helped you
overcome that would have been helpful, is there?    Do
n't know.  It's like you keep flipping
a coin and it keeps coming up tails and
then finally, well, it came up heads.    It was
like all these things went wrong
over and over again for 2 years.
Yes.
And he could have
totally justified himself by sending me an email
saying he was going to close, and I would say,
"Yes, that makes sense."  I would have no
objection.  And in the end it worked
.    It
's interesting; I think that's the
story of almost every success story.  And if you
're not willing to go through the
difficult times, you probably won't
reach the successful times.
Very good.  Keep going.  Good luck.
Very good.  Thank you, Michael.